bom
desde criança eu me deparei com a
pergunta que sempre me deixou muito
confuso
qual a alternativa das polarizações
pobres e ricos negros e brancos homens
mulheres sempre existem valorizações e
até então ninguém oferecia uma
alternativa de alguma forma aquilo me
incomodava de alguma forma aquilo fazia
com que eu influencio influenciava nas
tomadas de decisões e inconscientemente
eu escolhi ser testemunha de uma nova
forma de organização social que não
necessariamente cai na armadilha das
polarizações sociais
mas a pergunta que eu quero fazer pra
vocês que foi a que eu me fiz neste
momento é o que influencia na tomada de
decisão de vocês ego status carreira
segurança poder o que influencia na
tomada de decisão de vocês porque foi
quando eu me fizesse a pergunta e eu
comecei a fazer isso para as perguntas
para os adultos que estavam do meu lado
eu comecei a aos poucos entender quais
eram nossas principais problemas
estruturais
isso começou quando estudava na escola
pública no interior de minas e no
momento em que ganha uma bolsa na escola
particular
eu percebi que não era normal até amigos
que levavam manteigueira para a escola
para colocar arroz e feijão 9 horas da
manhã tamanho para os irmãos almoçar em
casa meio dia porque até então essa
realidade do meu bairro tava normatizada
e quando me deparo com escola onde as
pessoas chegam de motorista e começa a
perguntar para as pessoas o que
influencia na tomada de decisão delas o
que faz elas dormirem tranquilas com
tantos privilégios mal distribuídas
uma distância de menos de 10 quilômetros
porque elas estão tranquilas em se
deparar com essa polarização e não mudar
a maneira como elas tomam decisões
e foi assim que de alguma forma eu
entreguei a minha vida de jovem
adolescente primeiro sonho fazer com que
ninguém precisasse levar merenda da
escola para alimentar a família em casa
e me falaram que se eu ganhasse bastante
dinheiro conseguia distribuir o dinheiro
entre as pessoas foi por isso que fui
fazer engenharia cair na ilusão de que
engenharia também dava dinheiro e dentro
da unesp de fato eu descobri qual era a
solução desses problemas porque no ano
que eu entrei na faculdade entrou de
greve
e aí eu fui estudar quais são os
principais problemas da universidade
porque estava tendo greve
me disseram que não falta de recursos e
foi olhar para os recursos e o governo
investe três vezes mais no aluno no
ensino superior do que no aluno do
ensino fundamental se tinha que fazer
greve provavelmente não era para os
alunos do ensino superior
aquilo começou a incomodar a me provocar
e eu comecei a perceber que talvez os
nossos problemas não fossem só sociais
quando eu fui me aprofundar nos números
eu vi que aqui no brasil se a gente pega
duas pessoas do mesmo gênero da mesma
idade que estudam na mesma escola e
moram no mesmo bairro mas tem raças
diferentes as pessoas negras têm 23
pontos 5 por cento de chances maiores de
serem assassinados do que pessoas
brancas
não é a minha opinião a estatística
a única coisa que separa a bia da duda é
a raça todos os outros fatores foram
levados em foram levados em consideração
e retirada dessa equação
mas não é só isso quem era para resolver
os nossos problemas estruturais é um
congresso 54% da população é negra 20%
da câmara federal é negra alguma coisa
tava um pouco mais errado do que
imaginei
eu fui olhar para os outros dados do
nosso país
juízes 15% de negras ministros do stf 10
ministros do executivo e da educação
saúde 0% o que está acontecendo
porque todos nós dormimos tranquilos com
tanta desigualdade no país e porque
ninguém oferece uma alternativa capaz de
reduzir desigualdades e junto com isso
criar um ambiente com economia
competitiva empreendedora porque a gente
fica polarizado
nesse discurso entre esquerda e direita
e não resolve os dois problemas
e foi no meio dessa percepção separando
o que é racismo individual do que é
racismo estrutural que eu percebi que no
fundo quando a gente entende o que a
estrutura
todos nós somos igualmente responsáveis
na solução desse problema porque todos
nós estamos alimentando essa estrutura
independentemente de onde esteja
isso foi o que me fez no terceiro ano de
engenharia tomar uma decisão radical que
provavelmente foi o que me trouxe aqui
de abandonar a faculdade e me dedicar a
uma ong chamada educafro onde eu
consegui colocar o meu ser humano a
serviço desse sonho fazer com que a cor
da pele não influenciasse na expectativa
de vida das pessoas de alguma maneira
usar aquilo que estava aprendendo na
engenharia para resolver um problema
social e dentro da unesp dentro da
educafro a gente conseguiu por exemplo
instalar a instaurar comissões
antifraudes da unesp para garantir que
todas as cotas reservadas para negros
realmente fossem utilizadas por negras
hoje de cada dez alunos que entram nese
nas cotas para negros 89 são brancos que
fraudaram as cotas
isso acontece nas universidades públicas
do país inteiro e essa ação foi a que
fez com que a gente tenha essa sangria
lá em várias outras universidades
comissões de averiguação de fraude
dentro do carro a gente conseguiu em
2017 fazer com que um ponto dois milhões
de jovens que tiveram intenção negada no
enem a prova custa 85 reais e um erro do
sistema estava fazendo com que eles não
pudessem solicitar isenção
a gente conseguiu fazer com que o inep
prorrogassem as inscrições por 30 dias
pra 1.2 milhões de pessoas
a gente fez com que o ministro da
educação
bebês em mãos uma denúncia que estava
provando que os reitores das
universidades públicas do nosso país
estavam desviando a finalidade da verba
que deveria ir para assistência
estudantil
então aquilo que era pra construir uma
casa para os alunos pobres poderia morar
enquanto estudam está sendo utilizada
para comprar condicionado na sala do
diretor para comprar um bebedouro mais
perto dele para reformar o banheiro da
administração a mesma verba
ele falou pra gente te em 2008 ano
eleitoral ele não podia fazer aquilo
agora isso ainda não foi resolvido
caso vocês queiram resolver se junta
exatamente isso foi o que me fez
perceber que no fundo todas as nossas
decisões são políticas
não existe separação não são os
políticos que tomam decisões políticas
se os alunos da universidade estão
tranqüilos em fazer greve quando eles
recebem três vezes mais do que o aluno
no ensino fundamental
isso é uma decisão política eu não tô
falando que tem que parar de dar
dinheiro pra universidade pública
estou falando que se a gente faz isso
por um lado faz sentido a gente olhar
por tudo e aí a gente fundou essa
plataforma chamada engajem negritude
para aproximar pessoas negras e brancas
pobre da política
a gente entende que quando tem pessoas
sensíveis à causa quando tem pessoas que
viveram experiências de vida parecidas
com as experiências de vida que um
brasileiro comum vive provavelmente
essas pessoas vão conseguir construir
políticas públicas melhores e essa é a
plataforma que a gente criou mas no meio
disso eu também me deparei com outro com
outro fato que me fez fazer uma
transição
a gente não podia responsabilizar só as
pessoas negras e brancas pobres para
resolver o problema
a gente precisava dar um passo a mais a
gente tinha que fugir dessa polarização
e no meio de muitas pressões com a
agenda dos presidenciáveis e outras
outras políticas que estavam os que
estão os candidatos em 2018
eu fui participar de um movimento
chamado acredito
é o que hoje eu entendo que é uma
testemunha de que é possível viver em um
lugar que vai além de esquerda e direita
que vai além das polarizações nessa foto
tem gente que estudou em harvard tem
gente que não terminou a faculdade todos
eles estão construindo o mesmo sonho o
mesmo projeto de brasil pessoas negras
em pessoas brancas televisão com homens
e mulheres todos juntos de 14 estados
diferentes de onde a gente chegou até
agora construindo uma nova forma de
fazer política apoiando pessoas que
nunca foram eleitas que nunca tiveram
mandato e que de fato representam a cara
do brasil em dez anos a gente tem
certeza que a gente vai eleger pelo
menos 10% do congresso com pessoas que
realmente representam a cara do brasil
e é assim que a gente tomar as nossas
decisões
lembra da pergunta o que influencia na
sua tomada de decisão
a única coisa hoje que está sendo capaz
de reunir pessoas tão diferentes de
origens tão diferentes de estado são tão
diferentes não é a nossa ideologia de
esquerda sempre direita
isso é irrelevante a única coisa capaz
de unir a gente são os nossos valores
porque eu tenho certeza que
independentemente de quem está do meu
lado
o movimento vai ser radicalmente
transparente
eu tenho certeza que o movimento vai
defender com garra dignidade e igualdade
de oportunidades
e aqui são só três exemplos mas nós
temos seis valores que nossa visão são
muito importantes como por exemplo uma
economia competitiva empreendedora e as
pessoas falam que isso é falta de
direito nem a gente precisa de uma
economia competitiva empreendedora no
brasil se as pessoas falam que a
diversidade é uma falta de esquerda eu
também tô nem aí a gente quer um
congresso que representa o país a gente
precisa de diversidade dentro do
congresso e são valores não é ideologia
isso é o que fez por exemplo no ceará a
gente conseguir inserir uma menina
transe nove anos que tinha sido
convidadas a não se rematricular em 2018
simplesmente porque era trans ea
diretora teve a cara de pau de escrever
um bilhetinho e mandar para a mãe
falando que ela não tinha infraestrutura
para receber identidade de gênero da
menina no ano seguinte
essa é uma das nossas ações aqui em são
paulo como muitas outras que a gente fez
então ao redor do país onde a gente
envolve a população na revitalização de
ambientes públicos e espaços públicos
começa a praça mas não ensinando a elas
como é que faz
mas dando ferramentas para que elas
tomem suas próprias decisões
nessa ocasião eles perceberam que o
parque estava abandonado porque o gestor
do parque é indicado político do atual
governo e eles se reuniram sozinhos
foram lá e fizeram uma nova eleição do
bairro chegaram para o subprefeito falar
olha temos um novo gestor do parque a
gente não quer saber do antigo ele foi
eleito pela gente está dado
o cara está lá até hoje sendo o novo
gestor do parque continua revitalizado
jovens como é como esses que se
envolveram num movimento receberam
ferramentas começaram a tomar suas
próprias decisões
mesmo com 16 anos e não sendo obrigados
a votar fizeram um movimento nacional
para fazer com que jovens de 16 anos
tirar seu título de eleitor para votar
em 2018 enquanto a gente vive um dos
momentos de maior descrença na política
na história da nossa democracia
jovens que simplesmente receberam
ferramentas conseguiram se reunir e eles
mesmos se engajaram na renovação
política que a gente acredita e por
último
isso é o que basicamente influencia na
minha tomada de decisão
quando eu vejo que as coisas têm
propósito e que elas têm valores em
comum
provavelmente esse ambiente é um
ambiente onde eu vou me sentir
confortável porque entendo que as
soluções propostas ali
provavelmente são mais universais do que
as soluções propostas fora do ambiente
que não que não têm valores sendo a
tomada de decisão
falta sedentárias não são pautas que diz
respeito só a grupos minoritários pode
acreditar é o que acontece hoje dentro
do congresso todos os dias quando
aquelas pessoas tomam decisões que
privilegiam pessoas que parecem com elas
aquilo é uma falta dentro da área quando
a gente toma decisões pautada em valores
a gente começa de fato tomar decisões
pautadas naquilo que é universal e que
faz sentido pra todo mundo e por último
a consciência de que não existe
separação então
não venho de um lugar onde eu acredito
que as minhas atitudes não influencia
nas de vocês e que vocês não influencia
na minha e é por isso que eu não estou
aqui apontando o dedo e
responsabilizando vocês ou qualquer um
de vocês pela ineficiência do nosso país
pela eficiência da nossa política porque
simplesmente não existe separação
então o convite é que a gente faça sair
daqui
carregando uma lente que além da união
que além de que é possível construir um
espaço e viver em um ambiente onde a
gente foge dessa polarização e consegue
construir uma solução real e concreta do
nosso país ea pergunta é essa é de
sempre não trazendo a verdade pronta a
gente traz ferramentas faz as pessoas
acessarem outras pensamentos que talvez
não estavam disponíveis
a gente devolve o que vocês gostariam
que influenciasse de tomada de decisão
de vocês a partir de agora esse é o
convite ea pergunta que eu estou fazendo
agora
quando a gente faz isso quanto mais
diversidade a gente coloca no meio
dessas tomadas de decisão provavelmente
a gente está construindo e usando a
nossa vida para algo que realmente
representa a pluralidade existentes do
nosso país e do nosso planeta
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]